the presidency of the united states of
america
is often said to be one of the most
powerful positions in the world
but of all the u.s presidents accused of
misusing that power
only one has left office as a result
does richard nixon deserve to be
remembered for more than the scandal
that ended his presidency
find out as we put this disgraced
president's legacy
on trial in history versus richard nixon
order order now who's the defendant
today some kind of crook
um no your honor this is richard
milhouse nixon the 37th president of the
united states who served from 1969
to 1974. hold on
that's a weird number of years for a
president to serve
well you see president nixon resigned
for the good of the nation
and was pardoned by president ford who
took over after him
he resigned because he was about to be
impeached and he didn't want the full
extent of his crimes exposed
and what were these crimes your honor
the watergate scandal was one of the
grossest abuses of presidential power
in history nixon's men broke into the
democratic national committee
headquarters
to wiretap the offices and dig up dirt
on opponents
for the re-election campaign
it was established that the president
did not order this burglary
but as soon as he learned of it he did
everything to cover it up
while lying about it for months uh yes
but
it was for the good of the country he
did so much
during his time in office and could have
done so much more
without a scandal jeopardizing his
accomplishments
uh accomplishments yes your honor
did you know it was president nixon who
proposed the creation of the
environmental protection agency
and signed the national environmental
policy act
into law not to mention the endangered
species act
marine mammal protection act expansion
of the clean air act
sounds pretty progressive of them
progressive
hardly nixon's presidential campaign
courted southern voters through
fear and resentment of the civil rights
movement
speaking of civil rights the prosecution
may be surprised to learn that he signed
the title
ix amendment banning gender-based
discrimination in education
and ensure that desegregation of schools
occurred peacefully
and he lowered the voting age to 18 so
that students could vote
he didn't have much concern for students
after four were shot by the national
guard
at kent state instead he called them
bums for protesting the vietnam war
a war he had campaigned on ending but he
did end it
he ended it two years after taking
office
meanwhile his campaign had sabotaged the
previous president's peace talks
urging the south vietnamese government
to hold out for supposedly better terms
which i might add didn't materialize so
he protracted the war for four years in
which
twenty thousand more u.s troops and over
a million more vietnamese
died for nothing hmm a presidential
candidate interfering in foreign
negotiations
isn't that treason it is your honor a
clear violation of the logan act
of 1799. uh
i think we're forgetting president
nixon's many foreign policy
achievements it was he who normalized
ties with china
forging economic ties that continue
today
are we so sure that's a good thing and
don't forget his support of the coup
in chile that replaced the
democratically elected president allende
with a brutal military dictator it was
part of the fight against communism
weren't tyranny and violence the reasons
we opposed communism to begin with
or was it just fear of the lower class
rising up against the rich
president nixon couldn't have predicted
the violence of pinochet's regime
and being anti-communist didn't mean
neglecting the poor
he proposed a guaranteed basic income
for all american families
still a radical concept today and he
even pushed for comprehensive
health care reform just the kind that
passed 40 years later
i'm still confused about this burglary
business was he a crook or not
your honor president nixon may have
violated a law
or two but what was the real harm
compared to all he accomplished while in
office the harm was to democracy itself
the whole point of the ideals nixon
claimed to promote abroad
is that leaders are accountable to the
people and when they hold themselves
above the law
for whatever reason those ideals are
undermined
and if you don't hold people accountable
to the law i'll be out of a job
many politicians have compromised some
principles to
achieve results but law breaking and
cover-ups
threaten the very fabric the nation is
built on
those who do so may find their entire
legacy tainted
when history is put on trial
you